[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTINE LO: Well,
good morning, everyone.
I'm really excited to be
here today to share with you
how we've used Google
Cloud Platform to analyze
genomic data.
So, a little bit about
myself, I'm Christine,
and I lead a team of software
engineers and bioinformaticians
at Myriad.
As a hybrid team, we're not
just interested in analyzing
genomic data, but we're
also interested in choosing
the right tools to
do so, especially
in a clinical lab
setting of our size.
So, first of all, who are we?
We are a genetic testing
lab with a mission
to deliver genomic
information to patients
at each stage of their life.
So this requires a deep
understanding of technology
across many different domains.
So, for example, we need to
have a deep understanding
of genomic data
to understand how
to choose the right tools
to gather and structure
genomic data,
interpret it, and then
ultimately deliver the right
information to patients.
So, that's from a
mission standpoint.
From a product standpoint, we
have three different products
for delivering genomic
information to patients
at different stages of life.
So, our first test is our
carrier screening test,
this is for couples who are
planning on getting pregnant
and want to know if
they are both carriers
for a recessive disease.
So we can screen for over
200 inherited recessive
conditions including
cystic fibrosis,
spinal muscular
atrophy, and Fragile X.
Our prenatal test is for
women who are pregnant.
And this test detects fetal
chromosomal abnormalities
as early as 10 weeks
into the pregnancy.
This replaces insensitive
ultrasounds and also invasive
amniocentesis.
And finally, our inherited
cancer screening test
is for men and women.
And it tests for BRCA1, BRCA2
related breast and ovarian
cancers, as well as
several other types
of inherited cancers.
So, to get a sense
of scale, this
is a broad market
with growing demand.
There are currently 4.2 million
pregnant women in the United
States annually, and
we've really only reached
the tip of the iceberg
in terms of delivering
genetic information to them.
With 1/5 of them receiving
carrier screening tests,
and 1/3 of them receiving
non-invasive prenatal testing.
The market for inherited
cancer screening
is even larger with more
opportunities for growth.
With 19 million women who meet
criteria for inherited cancer
screening, and only
1.5 of them actually
receiving preventative testing.
So, how do we do this?
We're a clinical lab.
And how do we actually
test these patients
for these different diseases?
So, it turns out the
typical flow of a sample
is actually quite similar
across all of our products.
We essentially receive a
tube of blood or saliva
from the patient and then we
sequence the sample in our lab.
Depending on those
product we will
do either high coverage
targeted sequencing,
or low coverage whole
genome sequencing.
After sequencing is
complete, we align the reads
to the reference genome
and look for variants
in that sample's genome.
After going through
QC, it then moves
into the variant
interpretation phase.
Variant interpretation
is the step
that is to determine
which variants
are disease causing or not.
Not all variants are
actually disease causing,
and so we need to find
the ones that are,
and actually calculate
risk as well in this step.
So, finally, once we have all
of the interpreted information
we are ready to send the
report to the patient.
So in this talk,
I'm going to focus
on how we use GCP
for the problem
of variant interpretation.
So, first, let's talk about
some of the challenges
of variant interpretation.
The challenges of
variant interpretation
come in two different flavors.
One is the scalability
flavor, and then the other
is the diverse
set of information
that we need to
interpret variants.
So, to really
understand the challenge
of variant
interpretation, we first
need to understand the
scale of the problem.
So how much data
are we dealing with?
So, as Myriad, we are the
largest molecular diagnostics
company, and we have tested over
two million patients to date.
All of our tests
are focused which
means that we test specific
genes and diseases that we have
predetermined are actionable.
Each product we test a different
set of genes and diseases.
But in total, we test for
over 200 genes and diseases.
So, what does this mean in
terms of base pairs sequenced?
Again, this depends
on our product
but we can think of, on
average, sequencing around one
million base pairs per person.
Some of our tests do low
coverage full genome sequencing
and some of our other tests have
a smaller region of interest,
but on average we will sequence
around one million base pairs
per person.
So, on the database level,
what does this mean?
We need to keep track of
all of the region sequenced
in a person.
So, to blow that
into perspective,
we want to keep track of
the one million times two
million base pairs that we've
ever sequenced in the lab.
We also want to keep
track of the variants
that we see per person.
So, most of the time, the
genomic sequence of a person
is the same as the
average person.
Variability in
humans are estimated
to be 1 in 1,000 base pairs.
So, a naive database
representation
of the number of variants
that we see per person
would be a million
divided by 1,000,
which is 1,000 variants
per person, multiplied
by the 2 million patients that
we have tested, or 2 billion
rows.
So, that gives you an idea of
the amount of sequencing data
that we need to keep track of.
For variant
interpretation, we want
to know what the number
of novel variants
are because we want to
determine for each variant
whether or not it's
disease causing or not.
So this graph just shows
that even though you've
been testing for a while, there
is a long tail of rare variants
that exist.
A vast majority of these
variants are benign.
But a small percentage
actually break the function
that they are in,
and the problem
of variant interpretation is
to determine which one of these
are disease causing or not.
So this gives you an idea
of the scale of the problem,
but we need to understand
the other challenge, which
is the many different
factors that
are used to determine the
classification of a variant.
So for each novel
variant we need
to determine if
it's disease causing
or not by gathering and weighing
different types of evidence.
So, you don't actually
have to read this,
but these are guidelines that
are produced by the American
Society of Medical
Genetics that just show
the multiple types of
evidence that one needs
to consider when determining
the classification of a variant.
I'm going to just highlight
one of these types of evidence,
which is a allele frequency.
Knowing the allele
frequency can really
help determine the
pathogenicity of the variant.
Because if we see
this allele occur
more often than the
disease itself occurs,
then it is less likely to
be a pathogenic variant.
And so you can classify
this allele as benign if it
has a high allele frequency.
So what is allele frequency?
It's pretty straightforward.
It's calculated as a
fraction, the number of times
that we see an allele in a
population over the number
of times that this particular
locus of the allele
was sequenced in the population.
This is fairly
straightforward but just want
to highlight that we need to
parse a lot of genomic data
to get this calculation.
For AC, which is
allele count, we
need to go through all of
the calls of every sample
to calculate this.
And for AN, which is
the number of times
that we've sequenced
a particular locus,
we need to go through all
of the region sequenced
in every single sample.
So that's a lot of genomic data.
Another type of evidence
is zygosity count.
So, zygosity count is similar
to allele frequency in that it's
counting the number of
times a certain genotype is
seen in the population.
So since humans are
diploids, we have two copies
of each of our chromosome.
One is from our mom, and
one is from our father.
So most people are the same
as the reference genome,
and so that makes them
homozygous for the reference
sequence.
Some people have a mutation on
one copy of their chromosome
making them heterozygous.
And sometimes a
person has a mutation
on both copies of
their chromosome,
making them homozygous for
the alternate sequence.
And in some rare cases,
a person actually
only has one copy
of the chromosome
at a particular locus, making
them what we call a hemizygote.
So for variant
interpretation, we're
really interested in
knowing the zygosity count
because if several
people are homozygous
for the alternate sequence,
then that makes this allele less
likely to be disease causing.
All of these
questions really fall
under a class of analyses
called tertiary analysis, where
we try to make sense
of sequencing data.
So just to contrast between
primary analysis, which
is really trying to interpret
the data that's coming off
of the sequencing machines
and output sequencing
reads, and contrasted with
secondary analysis, which
aims to assemble and align
the reads to a genome and call
variants.
Tertiary analysis tries to
make sense of this variation
in a biological way.
So other types of
questions that we
may want to ask when we're
doing tertiary analysis
would be how often do we
see a combination of alleles
together in one patient?
We also might want to
calculate these metrics
on different segments
of the population.
So we may want to segment
by ethnicity, for example.
Sometimes an allele can
have a high frequency
in one ethnicity,
but not others,
and that would give
it enough evidence
to classify it as benign.
We may also want to
segment by gender
because there are some diseases,
like cystic fibrosis, that
have different
outcomes for gender,
and so you might want to look
only at the female population
if you want to assume
a healthy population.
Again, we always, when
calculating these metrics,
we do want to assume that
we have a healthy population
so we potentially
want to sequence out
any patients with any
sort of testing indication
that's not routine
carrier screening.
That means that they
might be getting
tested for a particular reason,
and they are probably actually
not considered to be part
of the healthy population.
Furthermore, for
research purposes,
we really want to make sure that
we are only including samples
that have consented to
research, and are in research
allowed jurisdictions.
So this is another type of
segmentation of population
that we are interested
in the research realm.
Finally, tertiary
analysis does not
need to be limited to
variant interpretation.
We may, for example, want to
infer ethnicity of patients
based on their
genetic information.
And this falls under the
realm of tertiary analysis.
So for a lot of
these questions we
can utilize public databases.
We can see if the
variant has been observed
in that particular
population, and look
at what the allele
frequency, and the zygosity
are in that population.
But some caveats are that these
populations databases are often
limited in size, which means
that rare variants are less
likely to be observed,
and if they are observed,
they may have a good chance
of being overrepresented.
Furthermore, we aren't actually
able to answer some questions
like co-occurrence without
knowing the genotype
at an individual level.
So, we do use these
public data sets
but these are just one type
of evidence that we consider.
Really, in order to provide
the best information
to our patients, we have to
leverage our own internal data
set of over 2 million patients.
With this larger
population, we have
much more statistical power
for variant interpretation.
And we can also go beyond
variant interpretation
and contribute back to science,
and do our own retrospective
analyses
So, again, when
we're doing research
we have to be very
careful in making sure
that our samples have been
consented for research,
and are in research
allowed jurisdictions.
But once we have
that population,
then we can, for
example, ask questions
like what is our carrier
rate to understand
more of the efficacy of expanded
carrier screening, especially
in a diverse ethnic population.
So, what is the carrier rate?
What is the at risk couple rate?
Those are all very interesting
questions to basically prove
efficacy of our tests.
With this platform
we can also observe
other patterns, such as coupling
patterns across ethnicities.
And we can observe many
other types of these analysis
with the data that we have.
So, really, hopefully
this motivates
building a system
for tertiary analysis
that requires tackling
two major challenges.
The first one is scalability,
and the second is flexibility.
We need a flexible system
because unlike clinical trials
or other hypotheses
driven projects,
the set have metadata
that might be relevant
for analysis is diverse and
potentially unknown upfront.
So, for example,
I could ask to see
all of the homozygous
individuals that
have a co-occurring carrying
pathogenic mutation.
One group may want to see
a certain set of metadata
for variant interpretation, and
another group may want to see
another set of metadata for
retrospective . analysis.
Furthermore, different groups
may have different restrictions
and access to data.
So we really need
a solution that
allows for flexible ad
hoc aggregation, and cyber
filtering of
variant information,
along with sample metadata.
We also need a scalable system.
We have a very large
population data set,
and this population data set
is growing every single day.
So unlike some of the public
databases, or academic cohorts,
this is a patient
population that
is growing every
single day and we
need to calculate these metrics
on the latest information.
So, I just wanted to talk
about one implementation
that we had before
using BigQuery.
So, we essentially hand built
a batch compute with Luigi
to calculate allele frequencies.
This pipeline was very
optimized for the one metric
that it needed to calculate.
We basically took
advantage of the fact
that this was a
recursive procedure,
and stored the
previous day's ACANAF
and would add to that
as needed as we got
new samples every single day.
But some of the problems
that we ran into
was that it was not flexible.
So, if we wanted to
add another metric
we had to build a completely
different pipeline.
And these would often
take weeks to run
on all of our historical data.
We could obviously
increase the instant size
and the compute power,
but it would still
be very compute intensive.
The other thing is
that it's really not
able to do ad hoc
aggregation and filtering.
You really have to be
thinking about what
is the information that
you want upfront, and then
and then building the
pipeline to calculate it.
So it's not a very
flexible system.
It's not scalable in the sense
that we aren't able to really
generate these metrics in an ad
hoc way with the amount of data
that we have in the
time that scientists
need to see them in real time.
So that kind of
motivates why we decided
to look into using BigQuery.
So this is just a very high
level architectural overview
of our system.
We have genomic
data and sample data
that is stored on
Google Cloud Storage.
This is ingested into
BigQuery using Dataflow,
and then right now, we have
just a very simple system
that persists the results
back into Cloud Storage.
So as new data comes in, we
add new rows to BigQuery.
So let me just go into each
of the individual steps.
So, this is the input data
that we're dealing with.
We store genomic
data and sample data.
I will go into a
little bit more detail
about what the genomic
data looks like.
The sample data is
anything that you
might want to know
about the sample,
so that would be gender,
ethnicity, the testing
indications, family
history, et cetera.
And for the genomic information,
we store this in a format
called GVCF
So, if you work
with genomic data,
you may be familiar with
the concept of VCF which
is the variant call format.
This is a file that
basically contains
all of the call information
for a particular sample.
A genomic VCF is very
similar to the VCF,
but it also includes the
homozygous reference regions.
So, essentially, this
allows us to distinguish
between regions
that were sequenced,
and regions that were not.
And, so you can
see that there are
large blocks of
homozygous reference
regions in this particular
sample that indicates
that this person
was sequenced here,
but no variants
were called here.
So, we have all of
this information,
genomic information
and sample information,
in our Google Cloud Storage.
The next thing we want to do
is transform and load this
into BigQuery.
So, the way that we
chose to do this was we
chose to parse the GVCFs
into, and transform them
into a parquet format.
With this, we're able to really
be flexible about the schema
that we ultimately
want in BigQuery.
And then at the
end of the day, we
have these parquet files
that we could potentially use
in other Cloud systems as well.
So, we parse our GVCFs,
every single sample,
transform them into parquet
and then append the new samples
to our BigQuery table.
And similarly, we do this with
the sample amount of data.
So this is an example of what
the BigQuery table ends up
looking like after we
load it in with Dataflow.
As you can see, it's
very similar to the GVCF
that I showed earlier.
It has your chromosome
position, ref, alt
and the genotype
information available.
So this is kind of a high level
overview of a sample query.
So to calculate
allele account, we've
split this up into
two steps, really.
The first is to parse
the genotype field
so that every single
row represents
a single allele for a sample.
And then after we do this,
after we flatten the table,
we are able to aggregate
all the alleles together
to generate the allele count.
And, so this is a simple groupi,
and then a count in aggregate.
So, I wanted to
talk a little bit
about some of the tricky
cases that we have dealt with,
because on the
surface level, this
may seem like very
straightforward to do.
But there are some
tricky edge cases
that we have to deal with.
And one of them is the
duplication of samples.
So, there's a possibility
that patients can get tested
multiple times in our lab.
And so, as a
result, there can be
multiple samples
that are associated
with a particular patient.
And we want to use
the most recent sample
because those are assumed
to be the most accurate.
In our previous
pipeline implementation,
we had to do this by
calculating them--
since we were calculating
the metrics incrementally,
we had to basically subtract out
the counts of the samples that
were duplicate.
And append that subtraction
to our final allele count.
But with BigQuery,
it's much easier
to deduplicate the
samples upfront,
and then recompute your metrics.
So, the other tricky case
that I wanted to talk about
is the deduplication
of alleles in BigQuery.
There can be multiple
representations
of the same allele So, when
working with genomic data,
we often define
alleles according
to the reference sequence.
But, as you guys may know,
there are many versions
of the reference genome, and
even with the same reference
genome, there are potentially
multiple representations
in very repetitive regions.
So this particular
example is an example
of an insertion deletion
and indel in a repetitive
region of the genome.
And you can see that
there are potentially
four different
representations of this allele
when compared to the
reference genome.
So this is a known problem
in the field of genomics.
There are many working
groups out there.
The Global Alliance
for Genomic Health
that are dedicated to
solving this problem.
So, how we've decided
to address this problem
is very similar to the way that
Global Alliance for Genomic
Health has also
addressed it, by using
a content addressable hash.
So, this is an
internally built library
that we built that is used
to tag alleles upfront.
So then we'll tag
them with the hash,
and then it makes it much
easier to combine alleles later
in the BigQuery pipeline.
And so finally, the real
advantage of BigQuery
is this continuous
ingestion of data.
We're able to essentially just
add rows to the BigQuery table
as we see more samples
coming through our lab.
And because it's so
easy to query on this,
we can just recompute our
metrics on the entire table.
So, then how do we actually
add more genomic calculations
in BigQuery?
It's as simple as writing
another SQL query.
So we can do this, and done this
for a co-occurrence, zygosity,
and dependent samples.
Furthermore, putting
it in BigQuery
allows us to do a lot of ad hoc
filtering, and segmentation. we
can filter and
segment on ethnicity,
and gender, testing
indication, et cetera.
So this really allows
us the scalability
that we were looking
for and the flexibility
that we were looking for in
terms of ad hoc filtering.
So, to wrap up, I wanted
to talk about application
in cystic fibrosis.
Cystic fibrosis is one of the
most common autosomal recessive
conditions according to ACOG.
It's caused by a mutation
in the CFTR gene, which
codes for the CFTR protein.
CFTR protein acts as a channel
on the membranes of the cells
to control for the flow of
water and ions in and out
of the cell,
especially in the lung.
So, if there's a pathogenic
mutation on both chromosomes,
this will cause cystic fibrosis.
It does this by basically
reducing the flow of these ions
and as a result,
there's a thick mucus
that tends to form on
the surface of the cells.
So this causes lung infections
and limits the ability
to breathe over time.
So, as a carrier
screening lab, we
have the advantage of having a
very large healthy population.
So with this very large
healthy population
we are actually able to
use our internal data
to reclassify some
variants that we previously
did not have enough
evidence to classify.
And as a result, they
were considered variants
of unknown significance.
Variants of unknown
significance are
just variants that we've
exhausted all the information
we know about this, but we
still don't know whether or not
it's disease causing or not.
These types of variants makes
it really difficult to counsel
patients because
it's obviously better
to know definitively whether
it's benign or pathogenic.
So this particular
variant, we wanted
to know how many
patients had this allele
along with another
pathogenic variant.
If this particular
allele occurs very often
with another pathogenic
variant, it's much less likely
that this is actually
a pathogenic variant
because the fact that we
have a healthy population
means that these people
are alive and well.
And they don't have
cystic fibrosis.
So we asked that
question, and it turns out
that there were quite
a few people that
had a co-occurring mutation
with a pathogenic mutation.
But then we wanted to
go a little bit further.
So cystic fibrosis is
an interesting disease
in that there is a variable
phenotype for males.
And so, it's very
likely that there
may be males with
cystic fibrosis
that don't even know it.
And so to filter out
the males, and just
look at the number of
co-occurring pathogenic
mutations in a
female population,
that gives us a much
stronger statistical power
to classify this
variant as benign.
And ultimately we
were able to do that.
We were able to downgrade
this variant to benign.
This is another example
where we actually did not
have enough information
to downgrade,
so we asked the
question, how many
patients has this has
this mutation co-occurring
with a pathogenic mutation?
And the conclusion
was that there was not
enough to downgrade.
And then finally, for
this particular variant,
we also were able
to reclassify it,
but we actually reclassified
it from pathogenic to VUS.
Given the answers to
some of these questions,
we actually think
it's probably benign.
But the fact that we're
not giving a false positive
to a patient is actually
is better than that.
So to downgrade this
variant, we actually
use both allele frequency,
and co-occurring statistics
to downgrade.
So it turns out that
this allele actually
occurs quite a lot in a
healthy patient population.
So, it's considered to be a
very, very strong candidate
for actually being benign.
[MUSIC PLAYING]